scott stay with us fox news alert bill  clinton is hospitalized with an  infection thank you the very latest our  own matt finn is with us matt what's  going on with former president clinton  uh we are now getting a statement from  former president clinton spokesperson  that says on tuesday evening president  clinton was admitted to the uci medical  center here in california to receive  treatment for a non-coveted related  infection he is on the mend in good  spirits and is incredibly thankful to  the doctors nurses and staff providing  him with excellent care we will keep you  updated on this developing story sean  all right and we do wish the former  president while unlike liberals that  just hate all conservatives they get  sick they don't care anyway matt thank  you